[Music]
people it's summertime or you screaming
for ice cream yet well when a young
couple opened a little ice cream shop in
Brooklyn New York seven years ago it was
an immediate hit with local residents
but that was just the beginning for
ample Hills Creamery their inventive
flavors each with a creative backstory
developed a cult following I sat down
the husband-and-wife duo this started it
all and toured their brand-new Factory
now the biggest ice cream Factory in New
York okay yeah let's go let's go I'm
ready for some ice cream okay - Jackie
kikuna I love these there's no better
taste of American culture than a scoop
of ice cream this is wet in here so it's
a vanilla cream cheese ice cream with
gooey gooey butter cake
she should know she's the CEO that's
chief culture officer of the ice cream
brand co-founded with her husband Brian
Smith so this is all brand new yeah it's
incredible this is some of this stuff
hasn't even turned on yet they're
whimsical flavor catchers are the
sensation known as ample Hills Creamery
now celebrating seven years with the
12th store coming to Los Angeles I think
that the thing for us was almost more
than ice cream that was the idea of
creating a sense of community a place
it's really important that we're
creating spaces where people feel
welcome with all people feel welcome it
all starts with a story and each of
their shots have their very own unique
flavor we have a shop in Gowanus go on
us is the canal in that neighborhood and
it's a toxic fetid waist up and so the
flavor there is called it came from
Gowanus and it's a deep dark chocolate
ice cream with a lot of things lurking
in it including white chocolate pearls
to represent the oysters that hopefully
will be part of the cleanup in the canal
so we go through a lot of effort to
start with story and then think about
flavors that can support that story what
do you think people get out of that your
customers I think that what it does is
it connects people to something more
than milk cream sugar and
the brand has some pretty famous
supporters Jerry Greenfield of the
popular Ben & Jerry's ice cream whose
ice cream does he loved that and then
there's the CEO of the Walt Disney
Company Bob Iger who loved ample hills
so much he put the store right on the
resort property in Orlando and teamed up
with the company to create a series of
limited edition Star Wars flavors what's
the best set of advice you got from the
two of them well I think to stay
authentic and to trust the instincts
that have gotten us to this place
they've sold more than 40,000 special
edition pints online which has helped
ample hills own bottom line overall
sales have grown from $600,000 from its
beginning to 10 million so would you
call this your dream come true oh my god
yeah it's insane it's crazy I mean to
step back and see the sign they put the
sign up two days ago and it just it gave
us chills helping to fund this new
location is a state-of-the-art dairy and
bakery plant in Brooklyn which also
houses an interactive exhibit for kids
where they can learn the process and
create their very own flavors stories
this is our home away from home the next
three weeks but for now the duo's
hitting the road scooping up their two
kids and embarking on a cross-country
trip to share their ice cream dream
before ending in California to open
their new store for us the real
excitement in traveling across the
country is making ice cream across the
country and telling different stories
across the country through ice cream
flavors next year the company is teaming
up with Marvel to make a child a
superhero ice cream that will be
available to everyone online this couple
is just there they're the dynamic duo I
love how they tell stories with ice
cream but girl don't you dare come back
here without freaking
do that an upset the dish room
[Laughter]